Hello and welcome to this video on Editor Utility Widgets.
For this exercise we'll be making a tool that will quickly spawn actors into the world.
For this tool I'm going to create a new asset.
So if I right-hand click and I come up to Editor Utilities
you'll see that there is an option for an Editor Utility Widget.
I will select this
and it's going to ask us to pick our root widget for the new Editor Utility Widget.
We have a choice of a stack box or a grid panel straight away.
But I'd actually like to use a canvas panel.
So I'm going to come down to All Classes
and you'll see here we have a canvas panel a little way down.
So we're going to select the canvas panel and push select.
Now that we've created it I'm going to rename this E-U-W for Editor Utility Widget
underscore quick spawn.
Now if I double click on this to open it up
we'll get a window that looks like this.
Now if you have used the UNG which is Unreal Motion Graphics
then this will look pretty familiar to you at this point.
What we have in the left-hand corner here which we have a library and a palette
kind of do the same things.
They just give you access to any of the components that you can add.
Down here we will have the hierarchy.
We're not going to do anything particularly complicated in this case.
We're just going to be adding buttons to the canvas panel.
Not going to have to go into too much detail here.
And in the center we have the viewport which will show what our menu system is going to ultimately look like.
Now on the right-hand side we have the details panel like usual.
This is contextual depending on what you have selected.
Like in the rest of Unreal Engine.
The animations panel at the bottom we are not going to use.
I'll just get rid of that for the time being.
One of the things you'll notice is in the top right-hand corner
we have a blue designer selected.
These are actually tabs.
Next to this there is a graph option.
If we go into graph this is going to look more like the blueprinting graphs that we've had before.
So this is the logic and the designer is what our widget is going to look like.
So as mentioned I am going to add a button in.
So if you look down here at the top here we have an option for an editor utility button.
I'm just going to drag that in to our canvas panel.
Drop it down.
You now see that we've got this in our top right-hand corner.
I'm quite happy with this being anchored to the top right-hand corner.
This isn't a class on the UMG so we're not really going to go over how to make this look pretty at this point.
So what I'm going to do is I'm also going to grab the text here
and I'm going to place that on top of my button.
I'm going to, and I want to change some of the details.
So the text here I'm going to change that to have the words Spawn Bush.
And I'm also going to reduce down the size of the font to 12.
You can see I need to do a drop down of the font to get that down.
Then what I'm going to do is I'm going to expand out the box a little bit.
So we now have a button which says Spawn Bush.
Now we want something to happen when we push this button.
So in order to do that I need to select the button.
If I come to the details panel and go all the way to the bottom,
you can see here we have a number of events.
So we can connect logic to any of these events we have on our canvas.
On clicked, on pressed, on released, on hovered, on unhovered.
We're just going to keep this simple and use on clicked.
So if you push the plus button, you're going to see we get an event
which is tied to that button click.
Now let's drag off of this and type print string.
Again we have our hello.
I'm going to compile and save and jump back to here.
Now to show an editor utility widget, what I'll need to do is right-hand click
and you can see there is an option here for run editor utility widget.
And as soon as I do, a new menu will appear with the Spawn Bush button.
If I push this, you can see that we get the hello coming up in the top left-hand corner.
I'm going to drag this and I'm going to dock it up here.
So that I can see this button when I'm working on it.
Right, so let's add some more code to this.
Delete the print string.
So the goal of this tool is to quickly spawn a bush in front of the camera.
Now we're going to use a line trace to do that.
The first thing we're going to need to do is get access to the camera.
And that's not necessarily easy.
If you right-hand click and you type in Unreal, that will give you access to the get Unreal editor subsystem.
And this is a very useful subsystem.
Primarily because you can do two things with it.
You can either get the level viewport camera info or you can set the level viewport camera.
So this is going to allow you control over the viewport camera.
So, for example, if I was to connect the set up to this button.
And whenever I push the spawn bush, it's going to move the camera to zero zero zero.
So that's what would happen if we had set the camera.
We're not actually going to set the camera.
I'm going to delete that.
We need to get its location.
The reason we want its location is because we're going to do a line trace again out the front of the camera.
So I want to get level viewport information.
And let's add our line tracing again.
So line trace by channel.
The camera is going to be the start location for this line trace.
Now, in order to get the end point, what we're going to need to do is we're going to have to add a thousand or however long we want to be able to trace to the vector location.
But in order to do that, we're going to need the direction that the camera is pointing it.
We don't really want it as a rotator.
We want it as a vector so that we can easily work with it.
And we can do that by dragging off of the camera rotation and type in get forward vector.
And so this is going to give us a one centimeter vector in the direction forward of the camera.
Now what we can do is we can multiply this, converting this to a float.
And I am going to multiply that by 1000.
And then I have to add that to the original camera location.
That gives us our line trace.
I can check this is working by drawing the debug.
I'm going to make it forward duration.
I'm going to increase draw time five should be fine.
And hit compile, save.
And now if I push spawn bush, I move, you can see the line trace.
Spawn bush is the line trace there coming out of the camera.
So the reason we're doing that is so that we can figure out the location that we want to place this spawned bush.
So I'm going to chop back in.
So the next thing that I'm going to want to do is spawn actor from class.
This class is going to be a static mesh actor.
And the spawn location is going to be a bit more difficult in this case.
So I have right clicked on the spawn location and I have split the pins because I'm just going to work with the location at this point.
There are two conditions in this instance.
If the line trace does hit something, we will want to spawn the actor in the location that it hit.
If it hasn't hit anything, we would want to spawn the actor in front of the camera.
So in order to do that, rather than writing a branch dependent on the return value, I'm going to do this all in the input to the location.
So if I drag off, I can type select vector.
Now with the select vector, the return value, I can plug in to the pick A.
So now if we hit something, it is going to place the bush in the first location.
If we don't hit something, it will place it in the second location.
So I am going to split the struct pin again.
I'm going to find the out hit location.
And that's A. So if the hit was successful, it would create it at A.
If it was unsuccessful, I'm going to do that.
I'm going to take the end of the line here.
So that would be a thousand centimeters in front of the camera.
Again, we won't be able to see anything unless we set the static mesh.
I'm going to type set static mesh.
That gives us our static mesh component.
And the mesh itself, I'm going to drop down, I'm going to search for bush.
And save and compile.
Now let's test this out.
So now if I'm down low and I push spawn bush, it will create the bush in front of me.
If I look into the sky and push spawn bush, it's going to create the bush
thousand centimeters in front of me.
So you can see how this is quite a simple tool where you can query the environment
and quickly create a bush in front of you.
Now that's good. That's just one button.
What I would like to do is convert this into a function so that we can create
multiple buttons all that spawn different things.
The way I'm going to do that is I'm going to zoom out a little bit here using the mouse wheel.
I'm then going to left click and draw a line around the whole section.
Then I will right click and select collapse to function.
And that's going to create a new function here.
And I am going to call this spawn static mesh.
There's one more thing I'd like to do. Let's jump into this.
And we have hard coded the SM underscore bush.
I'd like to choose this every time we run the function.
So I am going to make this easier to see.
What I'm going to do is I'm going to drag the new mesh and I'm going to drag it onto the input purple node here.
And you can now see that is set as an input.
If I compile, jump back to the event graph here, I can select bush.
And we have the spawn static mesh here.
Now, if I was to jump back to the designer.
So I duplicated this button.
I duplicate this button, move it over here, change the text.
So it says spawn chair.
And I come down to the bottom.
Oh, no, with the button selected, I come down to the bottom.
Add another event on clicked.
Then I can grab this function.
Press control and D for duplicate.
Connect it up. Now change that to share.
And hey, Presto, we have SM underscore chair.
And you can now see we have a new button up in the top here that says spawn chair.
And now with one button, I will spawn a chair and with the other button, I will spawn a bush.
Now, it's a very straightforward example here, but you can see how something like this could be built out.
And this is often used in conjunction with more complicated assets, which have different settings required.
So excellent. That is our second tool completely created, the quick spawn.
Now, again, what I'm illustrating here is the trigger points.
There's a big focus on the trigger points because there's lots of different functions, lots of different things that you can do with tools.
But what's useful to understand is what kind of tool you create so that you know how to trigger it, where the best option is for triggering it.
Thank you very much. In the next video, we will be looking at working with assets in the browser.
We will be creating an editor asset utility.